نستضيف في هذه النافذه المحلل العسكري
اللواء فايز الدويري كذلك ستكون معنا
الزميله سلام خضر على الخريطه التفاعليه
ومع سلام سنبدا
ب يعني متابعه ما يجري ميدانيا من خلال
هذه الخريطه وسير المعارك ما الذي حصل
اليوم سلام بينما تسارع الدبلوماسيه بحسب
فاينانشال تايمز للوصول الى حل ينهي الحرب
على قطاع غزه تقول ول ستريت جورنال ان حده
القتال قد لا تشي بان الحرب ستنتهي قريبا
ومن هذه النقطه سنبدا مناطق قطاع غزه
المختلفه اليوم عادت لتشهد اشتباكات سنبدا
من الشمال قبل اسبوعين يوف جالنت وزير
دفاع القوات الاسرائيليه قال ان قواته
انهت العمل في شمال قطاع غزه وانها قضت
على قدرات المقاومه اليوم عادت المنطقه
الغربيه الشماليه الغربيه من مدينه غزه
لتشهد اشتباكات بين قوات الاحتلال وفصائل
المقاومه وهناك استهدافات ايضا من قبل
كتائب القسام وسرايا القدس لعدد من الجنود
وايضا الاليات العسكريه في هذه المنطقه
وكان هناك اطلاق صواريخ من قبل سرايا
القدس على مستوطنات وبلدات اسرائيليه عند
الغلا عند المنطقه الشماليه في غلاف غزه
المنطقه الوسطى ايضا تشهد اشتبا كات وفي
المكان عيني حيث شهدنا قبل ثلاثه ايام في
المغازي ذلك الكمين المحكم حين فجرت كتائب
القسام مبنى بجنود اسرائيليين وقتلت اكثر
من 20 جنديا امس كان هناك ايضا عمليه
نوعيه استدرجت كتائب القسام قوه اسرائيليه
الى داخل نفق فجرت النفق بالجنود
الاسرائيليين وكان هناك قوات مؤازره ما
زالت تنتظر قوات ريه مؤازره للقوه التي
يفترض انها توغلت داخل احد الانفاق ايضا
استهدفتها واليوم هناك قصف لقوه تتمركز
عند الحدود ما بين البريج والمغازي
استهدفتها كتائب القسام وايضا سرايا القدس
بعبوات وب صواريخ محموله على الكتف صواريخ
مضاده للدروع بطبيعه الحال واصابت اليات
وجنود ولكن ما زالت المنطقه الاكثر حده من
حيث العمليات العسكريه في جنوب القطاع هي
خان يونس المدينه وخان يونس ايضا المحافظه
قبل ان نقول اين تركزت العمليات ركزت
اليوم قوات الاحتلال في غارات جويه على
المناطق الشرقيه لمحافظه خانيونس تعرضت
الزنه وبن سهيلا وخزاعه لقصف مدفعي وايضا
قصف بالطائرات غارات مركزه في محاوله من
قوات الاحتلال لتحييد تلك المنطقه ومنع
التوغل منع توغل كتائب القسام وفصائل
المقاومه باتجاه منطقه العمليات هذه هي
صوره اقرب لمدينه خانيونس واطراف مدينه
خانيونس شاهدنا اليوم فيديو لكتائب عز
الدين القسام تتحدث عن او ترينا حجم
الاشتباكات ومدى قرب هذه الاشتباكات
شاهدنا في المنطقه الغربيه على الاغلب وهي
المنطقه التي تتركز فيها حده الاشتباكات
دبابات اسرائيليه تتوغل الى داخل احد
الاحياء والاذقه شارع ضيق كما شاهدنا وثم
راينا دبابه واحده على الاقل تنفجر بفعل
قذيفه محموله على الكتف اطلقها مقاوم من
احد المباني المجاوره من نقطه مرتفعه
الملاحظ في هذا الاستهداف وهذا طبعا سيشرح
لاحقا الزميل حسن مع اللواء الدويري ان
الاستهداف تم ل البرج برج الدبابه او برج
الاليه ربما هذه واحده من نقاط الضعف التي
قد تؤدي الى اعطاب الميركافا بطبيعه الحال
هذه الامور سيشرح اللواء لاحقا ولكن ايضا
في العمليات في منطقه خانيونس هناك
اشتباكات عنيفه في المنطقه الغربيه وايضا
اشتباكات عنيفه في المنطقه الجنوبيه
وهناك كما درجت عليه قوات الاحتلال عند
التوغل وفي ب محاوله لاتاحه المجال امام
تقدم الياتها قامت بتفجير عده منازل
ومباني في المنطقه الجنوبيه من خان يونس
وهذه الاشتباكات تقول كتائب القسام وفصائل
المقاومه انها اوقعت اصابات مباشره في
صفوف قوات وجنود الاحتلال المتوغلة
في السياق مع الزميل حسن واللواء الدويري
شكرا لك سلام فعلا سياده اللواء
سنبدا من من الخريطه ايضا ما الذي تهدف
اليه قوات الاحتلال الان في اليوم ال13 ع
لهذه الحرب والمعارك قد عادت الى الشمال
الى شمال غرب مدينه غزه فضلا عن عما يجري
في الجنوب في خان يونس وجنوبا ايضا يعني
في المنطقه الش الماليه كما اشارت سعم هو
عمليه اشتبك اشتبكات محدوده امم يعني
عادت قوات الاحتلال لممارسه نفس الدور
الذي كانت تقوم به قبل معركه جباليه
والتفاح لانه عندما نتحدث عن جباليه
والتفاح والدرج تم الزج بقوه كبيره كتيبه
دبابات كتيبه مظليين سريه هندسه مقاتله في
كلا الاتجاهين وبالتالي الان لا نتحدث عن
عمليات توغل محدود لاغراض لاهداف معين
فبالتالي انخفضت
وتيره التصعيد في المنطقه الشماليه سواء
هو مقتنع بانه انجز المهمه ام انه اصبح
يعاني من خسائر كبيره في ظل معارك الوسط
والجنوب شمال شمال غرب
غزه الان هذه المنطقه ليست المره الاولى
التي تدخل فيها الوحدات هذه شارع الرشيد
وبالتالي شارع الرشيد ينعطف من قبل مخيم
الشاط باتجاه الشرق لانه غير موصول منطقه
الشاطئ الشارع الرشيد لا يستمر ينزل الى
الى الوسط ومن ثم يتابع طريقه فبالتالي
عندما تصل الى هذذه النقطه تصطدم
بالمقاومه الموجوده
في الشيخ رضوان فتبقى هي عمليات اشتباك
محدود وكانت في صور اقمار صناعيه قبل
حوالي اسبوع كان في تلك اللقطه كان مجمل
الا اليات المتواجده من جنوب المينا حتى
اخر نقطه 20 اليه وش مينز يعني رقم متواضع
لكن اذا ذهبنا الى الوسط الوسط
العمليات كل جانب الان يعني كانت معارك في
البدايه قويه تعرضت قوات الاحتلال الى
نكسات كبيره كانت كثيرا ما تتراجع باتجاه
السياج ولكن نجحت ال الفرقه 99 بعد ان تم
استبدالها بدل الفرقه 36 في مقاربه عسكريه
مختلفه تمكنت من تجزئه المجزا فصلت
المخيمات البريج عن النصيرات الصيرات عن
الزوايده الزوايده عن المغازي المغازي عن
البريج وبالتالي بقيت محاصره لكنها حتى
هذه اللحظه لم تستطع ان تدخلها علما علما
يوجد ثلاثه الويه رئيسيه ووحدات نخبه اي
ما يعد اربعه الويه مازالت تشهد اشتباكات
مناطق الوص انما لا لا يوجد هناك محاولات
هجوم واقتحام واجتياح معظمها اشتباكات
بالنار ومحاوله اجراء عمليات تسلل طيب
بالانتقال الى الجنوب الان المنطقه
الجنوبيه الان هي الموقعه الرئيسيه كما
تحدثت سلام الان
تفضل خان يونس الان يعني دعنا كذلك الان
لو سمحت شارع صلاح الدين تشر لنا من
الشمال للجنوب
شرق صلاح الدين شيء وغرب شارع صلاح الدين
شيء اخر نعم الان المنطقه الشرقيه كان
يوجد فيها القوه الرئيسيه من
القراره وزنه حتى خزاعه هذه هي منطقه
الجهد الرئيسي حقق انجازات في البدايه من
شمال عبسان الجديده ومن جنوب عبسان
الكبيره على الاطراف الخارجيه وبالتالي
بقيت منطقه الوسط تحديدا بني سهيلا يقوم
بتنفيذ عمليات قصف وعمليات تدمير لمربعات
سكنيه عندما يستطيع الدخول لكن لم يستطع
ان يتثبت بالمطلق وبالتالي بقيت هذه
المنطقه عصيه عليه ذهب باتجاه باتجاه خيار
اخر اي الخيار الاخر هو من خلال الحروب
السابقه والحروب الحاليه هذه المنطقه كانت
تعتبر منطقه عصيه عليه فبالتالي هو الان
دفع بقوات من اي من اليوم الاول من كوسوفي
م على القراره على المطاحن
على ابراج الحمد او ومن ثم وصل الى
المواصي جوش قطيف نعم وتوقف لفتره فتره
طويله تقاس بالاسابيع لم يحقق انجاز طيب
ثم دفع بجهد اخر تعزيز له من من جنوب بن
سيلا من الفخاري باتجاه قيزان النجار وعمل
تماس الى الجنوب الشرقي من مستشفى ناسر
الاسبوع اسبوع الماضي اشتدت المعارك في
تلك المنطقه لانه عزز بهجوم ثالث من منطقه
شارع خمسه باتجاه الامل فاصبحت الان هذه
المنطقه تهاجم من الشمال من ال من الشمال
الغربي حتى الجنوب الشرقي هذه المنطقه
كامله فيها هجمات حقق اختراقات لكنها ليست
اختراقات عميقه وبالتالي يوجد الان يتموضع
في في بعض المناطق تقريبا حوالي ست مناطق
الا التي يتموضع بها سواء البلديه سواء
الكتيبه السجن الكبير البوليتكنك هذا في
خان يونس نعم نعم طيب الجزيره حصلت على
مشاهد لا استهدافات لاشتباكات حصلت مع
قوات الاحتلال في خان يونس نتابعها سويا
ثم نحلل تلك
المشاهد
يعني قاذف تاندو تي بي جي هذا التي بي جي
اللي ضد المباني هي الان موجه باتجاه مبنى
معين هي
اطلق المقذوف شاهدنا الشرايا او تناثر
الحطام دعنا
نقول الان هذا هيكل دبابه
لانه البرج موجود وبالتالي استهدافه كما
كما ذكرنا سابقا لاستهداف من من الاعلى و
كما ذكرت سلام قبل قليل باتجاه نعم يبدو
من احد الادوار العليا وكان في موقع رمي
واتجاه الرمي باتجاه هذه البابه واضحه
ايضا اه لانه المدفع واضح بصوره
كامله على سيره ت بيجي ديعو احرونوت ذكرت
بان الياسين 105 وتي بي جي يبدو انها
الاكثر فعاليه والاكثر ايلاما بجنود
الاحتلال وب الياته نعم لهذا الكلام دقيق
وصحيح لانه معظم العمليات تدمير الاليات
اما ت تي بي جي او تاندم والتي بي جي
والتان دوم تقريبا ق قريبات جدا نفس
التصميم الى حد ما انما يبدو هناك
اختلافات بسيطه لكن من حيث الكفاءه
والفاعليه نفس الكفاءه والفاعليه وبالتالي
التي بيجي شاهدنا عمليات قصف المباني
والياسين او تاندم نفس الشيء هذه الطائره
المسيره صغيره الحجم طائره استطلاع مزوده
بكاميرات متطوره تعطي تنقل صور حيه بث
مباشر نعم
وصور 3 دي وبالتالي تقدم قراءه وهذه ترسل
المعلومه الى القاده في الميدان يعني قائد
وهو يقود العمليه العسكريه يقرا يقرا
الارض التي امامه بصور ثلاثيه الابعاد رغم
رغم صغر حجمها
ام من جديد هذه المشاهد وكنت تتحدث عن
الاسلحه
المستخدمه كان لاف ايضا يديعوت احرونوت
عندما ذكرت تحدثت عن فعاليه الياسين 105
والتي بيجي
انها انه الحديث عن هذه الاسلحه جاء بعد
عمليه او الهجوم المركب في
المغازي يا سيدي يعني الان
سواء كتبوا بعد او قبل تحدثوا بعد او قبل
من اول فيديو شاهدناه ود شاهدنا جميع
الفيديوهات نعم كل
اصدارات القسام تصل الجزيره نشاهدها نتحدث
عنها نحلل هذه الاسلحه هذه الاسلحه هي
تصنيع محلي مش مستورده نعم معظم الاسلحه
التي تستخدمها المقاومه باستثناء النزر
اليسير
لبعض اسلحه الميم
دال
جميعها تم تصنيعه محليا تحت الانفاق كما
يقال داخل الانفاق
وجميعها اعتمدت مقاربه الهندسه العكسيه
نعم وبالتالي الهندسه العكسيه قانونيا لا
يطارد لانه الصين تعتبرها وبالتالي نجحوا
جدا وفي ايجاد هذه الوسائل المتواضعه
الفاعله هذه طائره درون معها
نختم سياده اللواء فيز الدويري هذه
النافذه التحليليه شكرا جزيلا لك
و شكرا مشاهدينا على المتابعه نعود الى
فدا وغرفه الاخبار